dans l'âme cieux bonsoir le premier
titre de l'actualité ce soir sur antenne
2 est en forme de ballon rond c'est bien
sûr le football avec la retransmission
en direct à partir de 20 heures de la
finale de la coupe de france entre
auxerre et nantes auxerre
le cendrillon de la coupe comme dirait
mes confrères sportifs opposé à l'une
des meilleures équipes de première
division alors qu'elle évolue en seconde
division nous allons y revenir tout de
suite mais avant les autres titres de
l'actualité la vienne messieurs carter
et brejnev ont commencé leurs
discussions qui devraient aboutir lundi
à la signature d'un accord visant à
réduire le nombre des armements
stratégiques des deux pays
au nicaragua pour la première fois
aujourd'hui on parle d'un départ
éventuel du président somoza alors que
dans le même temps les combats
s'intensifient dans la capitale et un
peu partout dans le reste du pays
en france réunion houleuse du comité
directeur du parti socialiste un
incident a opposé la nouvelle direction
du ps au courant minoritaire de
messieurs mauroy et rocard monsieur
mauroy à qui l'on reprochait notamment
une réponse faite cet après midi au
journal le monde dans laquelle il
critiquait la façon dont monsieur
mitterrand avait conduit la campagne
européenne a affirmé notamment que la
nouvelle direction du ps entendait faire
du parti socialiste un parti
monolithique monolithique un peu à
l'image de celle du parti communiste la
réunion a été suspendue et lors il a été
décidé que les socialistes se réunir est
en convention nationale le 24 juin
prochain pour justement examiner les
problèmes posés par les résultats de ces
dernières élections européennes
nouvelle série d'attentats du flnc le
front de libération national corse une
vingtaine d'explosions au total la nuit
dernière en corse dans la région de caen
et à paris des attentats qui n'ont pas
fait de victime mais d'importants dégâts
voilà donc pour l'essentiel de
l'actualité que nous développerons à
20h45 à la mi temps de la finale de la
coupe de france de football mais en
attendant tout de suite nous allons
retourner une première fois au parc des
princes pour retrouver thierry roland et
bernard père qui vont nous donner tout
de suite je pense des précisions sur la
composition des équipes qui était
incertaine jusqu'au dernier moment
thierry oui et bien en ce qui concerne
l'équipe d'auxerre s'est entraîné avec
l'équipe de nantes sur la verte pelouse
du parc des princes un parc des princes
archicomble évidemment comme le veut la
tradition de la finale et le doute plane
toujours en ce qui concerne le poste
d'avant-centre entre truchot et
jean-marc cher ce avec usher a été
blessé et puis ma foi il s'est entraîné
avec ses jeunes camarades alors on peut
très bien le voir arriver porteur du
numéro 9 c'est la dernière incertitude
qui pèse sur scène finale de la coupe
qui va être présidée par le président de
la république valéry giscard d'estaing
qui honorera de sa présence cette 62ème
finale de la coupe de france
quant à l'équipe de nantes et via ma foi
c'est l'équipe attendue l'équipe type
puisque tous les blessés ont été remis
sur pied bertrand demanes dont on
distingue mal le nom dans le public vous
le voyez très nombreux muller le milieu
de terrain et aussi les
les autres joueurs comme tussauds qui
était incertain ils sont tous là c'est
l'équipe la meilleure équipe possible
qui va essayer donc de donner à nantes
sa première coupe de france puisque
nantes a déjà été trois fois en finale
et trois fois les canaris comme on les
appelle ont été battus bien une finale
qui se présente bien ma foi il fait beau
il fait bon il y a beaucoup de public
pour but que nous ayons un bon match
voilà c'est tout ce que tout le monde
espère fait rire on se retrouve donc
dans quelques minutes mais puisque nous
sommes dans le sport reste 11 i d'abord
avec la course cycliste du midi libre
aujourd'hui avant dernière étape c'est
le belge de meyer qu'il a remporté au
sprint mais la première place du
classement général est toujours occupé
par l'italien guiseppe saronni qui a
toutes les chances de l'emporter demain
on revoit les sprints et sur ces images
de cet après midi avec la victoire de
marc demeyer ou victoire en force comme
on dit
comme dirait robert chapatte voilà
tennis coupe davis la france est
qualifiée dès aujourd'hui aux dépens de
la suisse en effet après les deux
victoires d'hier en double cet après
midi yannick noah est mort et ont
longtemps porté à l'issue d'un match
médiocre qui assure tout de même la
qualification de la france qui
rencontrera prochainement la
tchécoslovaquie on voit là le dernier
échange
décidément il est dit que la france sera
toujours du mal à trouver une équipe de
double heureusement aujourd'hui
l'adversaire n'était pas de taille les
suisses günthard gros mais n'y a ici au
fond du court étant loin de former une
paire redoutable
on pensait donc que noah et meurent est
on allé gagner facilement en trois sets
et bien non ils ont commencé par perdre
le premier set 6 jeux à 2 accumulant les
erreurs
menant ensuite 5 à 2 dans la deuxième
manche et se sont fait remonter pour de
l'emporter que 7 à 5
heureusement ils trouvaient leurs rimes
dans la troisième et quatrième sets
qu'il gagnait 6 2 et 6 3 grâce à cette
victoire les français se qualifie pour
le prochain tour de la coupe davis qui
aura lieu ici-même à roland garros dans
un mois mais l'adversaire sera cette
fois la tchécoslovaquie et il faudra ce
jour là que les jeunes français sortent
le grand jeu comme ils savent
quelquefois le faire
voilà le tiercé de demain c'est la
réouverture d'auteuil alors au galop
pierrette brès vos pronostics parce
qu'on ne veut surtout pas louper le
début de la coupe de france vient tout
d'abord je vous propose de regarder le
film que j'ai effectué à l'entraînement
avec une interview de deux des onze
valeurs déjà le favori de la voilà que
ça va venir vous pouvez peut-être
commencer votre papier pendant que les
images on les attend d'un moment à
l'autre les voilà une fois de plus les
mêmes chevaux on se retrouve et et aux
foulées tony haurat à se battre contre
qui est facile je pense que raccourci un
très bon cheval qui va effectuer sa
rentrée l'obstacle kévin gagneul est en
place qui a très bien couru c'est d'un
quand on soutient chaque hongrie taquile
qu'un cheval ou encore que novice aux
obstacles je pense qu'ils aient promis
un très bon avenir
et puis car vicky très régulier teofilo
un troisième quatrième français à ce
show là c'est là parce que je lui
donnais même dans les pronostics
il a effectué une bonne rentrée il peut
voir accuser quelqu un petit peu de
progrès sur sa rentrée
c'était bien ils sont très bien très
très bien excellement est enfant il est
bien le cheval est très bien
aussi optimiste parmi les 15 portant des
gants pose des cats ont tous ont une
bonne chance à défendre aussi les
rapports du tiercé devrait être
intéressant je prends donc le risque de
placer en tête de mes pronostics great à
pile un outsider derrière lui encore un
outsider un enfant qui n'a que de bonnes
performances à son actif car vicky qui
sera l'un des favoris valable tout comme
teofilo anthony qui reste lui sur une
victoire derrière lui je mettrais hime
rieuse qui a terminé troisième de
teofilo tony et qui a une revanche à
prendre
ensuite pas vigneault il vient de gagner
le prix amadou il sera lui aussi favori
sous dos mon cheval extrêmement régulier
et recolle de roberty pourrait bien
créer une surprise
ils termineront la sélection je vous
rappelle leur numéro de pmu 12 6 7 5 8 2
4 et 9
voilà merci pierrette vous êtes dans les
temps vous n'avez pas débordé on va se
quitter maintenant quelques instants un
peu moins de quatre minutes et on se
retrouve ensuite cette fois ci pour le
vrai aidée par le coup d'envoi de la
finale de la coupe de france de football
a tout de suite